comenzó el silencio electoral un periodo
en el que se prohíben los mítines y la
propaganda electoral en honduras y que
sella el final de una campaña marcada
por asesinatos por motivos políticos y
acusaciones cruzadas
según las últimas encuestas los votos en
la contienda presidencial estarán
divididos entre dos candidatos opuestos
la izquierdista xiomara castro de zelaya
esposa del derrocado presidente manuel
zelaya y el conservador nasry asfura y
determinarán directamente quién será el
sucesor del actual presidente juan
orlando hernández acusado de corrupción
y complicidad en crímenes de
narcotráfico
[Música]
la candidata de la izquierda también
promete la reducción de sueldos de los
funcionarios del estado la mejora del
sistema de salud y el aborto por tres
causales una propuesta condenada por el
candidato oficialista al mismo tiempo en
que asegura que impulsará la creación de
nuevos empleos en el país dar
oportunidad a entender
llevar una oportunidad que la gente
lleve un sustento a sus casas salud y
educación el domingo los hondureños
también elegirán los nuevos diputados
del congreso nacional y los alcaldes
municipales y se enmarcan en medio de
una creciente pobreza que podría
alcanzar una tasa del 75 por ciento con
una situación empeorada por la pandemia
en un país que solo ha vacunado a cerca
del 37 por ciento de sus ciudadanos
algunos observadores alertan que las
elecciones podrían repetir el escenario
de 2017 1 que llevó a miles de
hondureños a migrar luego el triunfo del
actual mandatario en unas elecciones que
consideraron amañadas